Please welcome Ike Barinholtz!
(audience loudly applauding)
Mwah.
Hello!
Hi, everybody.
Now let me get numbers right.
Two, four, and seven are the ages of your three girls.
Yes, I have three daughters (Drew loudly gasps) and yeah,
we are swimming in estrogen here, Drew.
Oh my gosh, do you ever have that weird feeling
like maybe it was your karmic destiny?
Like these girls needed your male energy
and you needed to be surrounded in a house full of women.
Like you were the man picked
to lead this pack and they need you
and you had to be balanced by their feminine energy somehow.
100%, 100%.
I was, my energies were very off, I was a real bro,
and now I'm a bra, I guess.
(Drew loudly laughing)
You did have a lot of interesting like friends and alumni.
I was really obsessed with Boom Chicago when you guys-
Yes!
Went to Amsterdam with the-
Yes.
I mean,
talk about some of the people that you've grown up with
in comedy and been surrounded by because it's quite a troop.
Yeah, well, this was a little theater
that a bunch of three guys from Northwestern founded
in Amsterdam in like 1994.
And I went there in like '99
and I was doing improv in Chicago.
And the folks that we were working with there
at the time were just my friends, but it was Seth Meyers
and Jordan Peele, and Jason Sudeikis,
AKA Golden Globe Best Actor, hello?
But Kay Cannon who directed Blockers,
and Liz Cackowski, and just all these
just amazing comedians.
And we were in Amsterdam
and I got to tell ya, I remember about 20% of it.
Now you have also amazing friendships with Mindy Kaling
and Amy Poehler.
Yes, yes.
You sort of grew up comedically with Tina Fey.
Like how did you and Mindy meet, may I ask?
Well, Mindy, I was a huge fan of Mindy's
'cause I loved The Office.
It's one of my favorite shows and I followed her on Twitter.
This is when Twitter was like fun and new
and kind of nice, I guess.
And I had started this show called Eastbound & Down-
The best!
With Danny McBride,
classic, classic,
and Mindy was kind enough to like
tweet about the show and how funny
she'd thought I was on the show, and we struck up this
kind of online friendship.
And then when she was doing her sitcom,
my writing partner Dave and I went to her house
to meet with her, and we actually wore like blazers
and we brought like flowers to congratulate her
on the show getting picked up.
And I think we really pulled the wool over her eyes
'cause she was like, "Look at these two suave gentlemen."
And then once she hired us,
she realized we're just like two absolute slobs from Chicago
who just wear like sweatsuits
and just watch a lot of TV on the couch
and eat a lot of sweets and nap.
Ike, you literally just described me
and my daughter Olive's weekend.
I'm not kidding, at one point I was like, "Do I vacuum?"
I'm trying to get her to like just vacuum up
all the detritus and crumbs on the couch.
It's like, I'm trying to find that hook, that bribe
that's gonna get her to do Mr. Sucky
on like all the, just crap everywhere.
And we did, we just soaked
in our own juices on the couch, watching TV.
Listen, if we're gonna stay on the couch all day,
we wanna watch something that's gonna fill our hearts.
And what I love about what you
and your fellow comedy alums is that there's heart
and you wanna have humor that has heart.
And that's what you put out there in the world
and your new movie Moxie, directed by Amy Poehler,
how was that experience?
I love her so much!
I mean,
she is the queen, she's the greatest.
I've known her since like the '90s
and she's always been the coolest, the funniest,
the hottest, like everyone loves her.
And when she called me and she's like,
"I'm doing a high school movie,"
at first, I thought, wow,
I'm still young enough to play a high schooler.
That's pretty cool.
(Drew loudly laughs)
But then I realized I'm the teacher and I moved on.
But it was so wonderful,
and then when I saw the movie,
I was just like my heart soared
'cause it was, it was sweet and it was funny,
but it also had this great message.
And to have a movie that really kind of shows
how important it is to be aware of of yourself
as a woman and be a burgeoning feminist
is pretty great for me.
It's like Amy's like a co-parent a little bit,
which is the way we think about it.
I think you're absolutely right.
(upbeat music)